there was this Last of Us knockoff that
has now been taken down from the
Nintendo eShop and I did try to buy it
on Steam but it appears to also be gone
but look at them
they didn't even try
they didn't even try to pretend it's not
Ellie that's so funny to me uh it's it's
called The Lost hope Dead Zone survival
the Lost hope Dead Zone survival yeah
and it gained traction a couple of weeks
ago and has now been taken off the eShop
which as an aside is definitely like an
issue Nintendo has they just don't
quality check
the eShop there's a lot of shovelware on
there I'm not at all surprised that this
got by um but it's been out for a minute
it has officially been
removed and so of trailers for the game
apparently though we can probably find
one let's have a look this is a trailer
that someone uploaded four weeks ago
nothing was ever the same since the
invention of the time machine
[Music]
time machine
Consciousness Corey Bala
okay
I mean but when the future turned out to
be darker than the darkest nightmare
great line when the future turned out to
just like my dreams look I don't I don't
know that Sony really needs to worry
about this one
it was time to intervene time to
intervene
he put the text on the screen I mean it
just looks like The Walking Dead at this
point
decision was made to send a man into the
future
prevent this feels like it's fake
the decision was made to put a man this
doesn't feel like a real trailer to save
the world from an
disaster it was time to intervene Brian
Lee a father
a hope
he finds himself alone in an apocalyptic
City okay where each step forward is a
new obstacle a new mystery to unravel
it's not looking that lost they're
losing me a bit faces
Naughty Dog wishes they could make a
game that looks this good that's all I'm
saying
on this journey through time into an
apocalyptic future stop saying
apocalypse
I want to play it so bad
this is really making me want to play
this game even that's so similar oh my
God
wow so that's
the trailer game has since been
removed from the eShop finally uh if we
head to the store Page it gives us a
nice 404 message the game came out late
June it appeared on the switch eShop the
game was a horrible looking Nintendo
switch exclusive that seemed to come out
of nowhere with a trailer that caught
the attention of the internet for all
their own reasons in the viral trailer I
totally missed it I don't even know this
happened most agreed it looked bad and
once people actually played it we
learned that it was probably the worst
game of 2023
being with highly buggy in only about 15
to 20 minutes long oh my God I'm so sad
I will never get to experience this
now this viral knockoff seems to quote
the attention of Sony which doesn't seem
to be a fan of The Last Hope as reported
by Eurogamer trailers and other videos
of the last type of being removed from
YouTube video unavailable no longer
available due to a copyright Claim by
Sony interactive entertainment LLC so we
know that the the YouTube videos are
being taken down because of Sony
foreshore uh but oh my God ads go away
dude please Kotaku leave me alone so at
this time we don't know if Sony
requested the game you removed from the
eShop if Nintendo took the step itself
or if the developers behind the game
removed out of caution could be any of
them hard to say there's a God of War
clone as well Leighton God of War
knockoff being sold on the Xbox store I
didn't know that existed God of warning
what is that real that's what about Euro
game where there's a new and fairly
cheap action game available on Xbox it
seems to start Kratos the game has the
not at all clunky title of war god Zeus
of child
[Music]
War God's use of child
that's way better than God of War
Ragnarok oh I wish I could have worked
on something this impressive dude my
legacy is in Ruins
they even got the
the little costume details
so that was the x button this is the Y
button yeah
I I have to I have to quit my job and go
work for hoop whichever Studio made this
immediately it's the smoothest thing
I've ever seen I love I love the attempt
I love it uh it appears this game which
is made in unity and release on July 26
is part of the Xbox creators program the
idea is to let smaller teams and
solidups use their consoles as Dev
equipment making it easier for you to
make games and sell them across P Xbox
and PC so this is a thing that is not
that uncommon across Game Dev where
people will make a very cheap like 20
game just in order to get access to
devtools that's honestly how like a lot
of really bad indie's crop up uh I just
don't know why you would even try to
risk copyright while doing that because
you can make something that's like
terrible and comes out and nobody plays
it why would you even try to make it eye
grabbing it's a really weird choice but
that is probably what they did is uh you
know make a game as fast as possible
something that barely functions just so
that you can get devtools it's not
unheard of so the Last Hope on switch
Eurogamer wrote this article when the
game was still available when it first
came out I presume The Last Hope on
switch an absolute disaster and the
worst game we've ever tested digital
Foundry investigates the dregs of the
Nintendo eShop this is so funny that
doesn't work for me this
kind of does
like it does look like her
the hair is you know close enough for me
I think they did a great job if you're
looking for a suitable alternative to
licking the toilet bowl West Connection
limited has got you covered they're
bringing a verify a veritable Buffet of
Unfinished barely functional smoking hot
garbage to the table but thanks LJ look
like Nintendo in building its catalog of
vetted bile West Connection has mastered
the art of the SEO game through a
collection of vaguely assembled words
designed explicitly to full customers
into wasting their money and time like
Call of Duty got Battlefield trial World
War battle heroes feel the Army's call
of prison Duty simulator
is that a real name are they just making
the game titles like SEO clusterfox oh
my God should I buy it I feel like I
should stream it world or battle heroes
field Army's call of prison Judy
simulator
bro are you kidding me this looks sick
oh my God it has blood and violence a
game in which you can get acquainted
with the hardships faced by soldiers in
the world war being in the role of
strategic General you'll be instructed
by type blow up the Strategic reserves
of opponents destroy enemy artifact
artillery radio towers and also help
your allies in killing the enemy General
you'll be given more than 10 types of
weapons to choose from including
grenades and the possibility of
hand-to-hand combat the ability to
select up to three weapons in the
in-game overlay as well as the choice of
hand-to-hand combat a variety of
locations will allow your eyes not to
get bored
why didn't I think to list that when I
was reviewing games back in the day a
variety of locations allowed my eyes to
not get bored this is straight up SEO
bait for kids that's what it is okay
what about uh counter bottle shooter Pro
a monster Target bottle shoot 3D game
strike pistol you can't it can't it
can't be there's no way
oh my God Nintendo the game
here is called
counter bottle shooter Pro and master
Target bottle shoot 3D game strike
pistol hey you know what I'll say about
this my eyes
they ain't bored shall we see their
video so this is
digital foundries video about The Last
Hope on Nintendo switch they consider it
the worst game they've ever reviewed
no punches so buckle up and enjoy the
ride I'm so ready dude I was not
prepared for the journey I would soon
take with the Last Hope Dead Zone
survival and other quote-unquote games
produced by the Junk Food Connection
limited oh you've never heard of them
cue the Montage
I mean
he looks so much like Nico Bellic from
GTA 4.
this looks pretty sick you're making it
look too cool
it just looks like they came out on the
PS2
cause they got driving mechanics
I feel like you'll ever sold at digital
Foundry even with the disclaimer text
that it does not represent actual
gameplay I was surprised to learn that
none of this stuff made it into the game
oh none of the stuff in the trailer is
even in the game
virtually no music and basically nothing
else resembling that trailer so if you
thought that trailer looked better
devastating I haven't seen anything yet
I thought the trailer looks so good I
want that game Heavy splash screen
followed by a completely static title
screen that resembles key art from
ubisoft's the device they've definitely
stalled after something backpack that
was probably AI extremely into a
desolate City with his back turn to the
camera thing the game then loads into an
exceptionally choppy first person
cutscene showing your character waking
up in a hospital room just walking down
welcome to the last hope I guess you
play as time traveling Commando Brian on
his quest to see Humanity he doesn't
look like Sony doesn't know what they're
talking first objective is to leave the
hospital and it's here that you'll start
to feel your soul slipping away this
Hospital consists of three rooms all
divided by loading screens your hospital
room a hallway just outside your room
and a staircase anyone familiar with the
unity asset store may recognize some of
the props used here
but I did Identify some of them for
instance they're using the zombies pack
V2 from Studio new punch to handle well
all of the zombies wow
[Music]
shelves in the grocery store come from
the supermarket gluttony pack by
nickelbolt you'll also find recognizable
car models
that pack did a great job I wouldn't be
surprised if the game's main characters
are hiding somewhere in the asset store
as well this is the Remake pretty much
the same for PlayStation 4 by the way I
think it's fair to say that it does have
a vision I can't tell the difference
what are you talking about yeah I don't
think naughty dog has anything to worry
about here do
fall in love with Brian like they did
with Joel yes look at Brian hey look at
his face how could you not fall in love
with Brian
I was sold from day one it's the life
behind his eyes that gets me I'm almost
impressed with how blatant a rip-off
this really is they didn't even try I
almost describe this as
oh my God
yeah it's the remosted version what if
you put it side by side with the
original version I feel like the outcome
would be varied I wouldn't be able to
tell the difference that's not fair
and that's a PS4 Pro this is on the
switch
I just feel like it's not fair and she
looks great
it's amazing the Last Hope is all over
the place that said while it's highly
variable it at least runs smoother than
World War battle here as field armies
call a prison Duty simulator
and speaking of glitches there's even a
door in a game that requires you to
press the E
yeah
oh my God I love it all storytelling is
handled via these text boxes which often
awkwardly intersect with others great as
I noted earlier there's no oh no I need
to read it hang on hang on give me a
second go your ponytail Defying Gravity
I don't talk to a woman unless her
ponytail
sticks directly from the back of her
head it's it is erect it's how you know
she's into it he is a soldier he has
never been home always on missions but I
love him I have called him the day it
all started and he was unavailable this
is why we went all alone with Mom I
still don't know where he is and I'm
sure he doesn't know where I am either
but it's so hard to find a phone around
here so I hope I'll be able to call him
when I get to safety
it's just so odd to find a phone around
it oh boy so his question was like
listen Ava Brian here
just a quick question what happened to
your father and she's like well he is a
soldier and always unavailable but I
love him so hard to find a phone around
here you know what
that's pretty relatable to a lot of us
you know a lot of people without dads I
do have a dad he's great he loves
calling me
um not to brag sorry if that's
insensitive but um I I just think they
really captured a lot of people's
struggles sometimes you want to call
your dad but it's hard to find a phone
around you you know what I mean I am a
soldier too what's your father's name
Brian Lee I am evily wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
no is it her dad the best plot twist of
all time I am
invested now she doesn't need a phone